Hey, here's a funny voicemail.
In light of Donald Trump deducting 70 grand
for haircut stuff.
Take a listen to this voicemail I got.
Hey, David.
This is Dave from California regarding Trump's
taxes.
I want to ask you a personal question.
Was Dufy Doug ducted the price of a haircut?
Right.
When you do The David Pakman Show.
Now, you know, you can.
So will you be doing that?
You know what's funny about this?
So so first of all, I don't spend set 70 grand
on my haircuts.
I spend 35 bucks, I guess, every two months.
So that's like, you know, I spend about two
hundred and twenty five dollars a year on
haircuts.
My accountant said it's one of those things
that I, I can I can do it as a business expense
if I want, because I'm getting haircuts for
a show that if I were audited, it could be
an area of disagreement with an IRS auditor.
But my accountant says I would probably be
fine doing that.
But no, I have not done that yet.
And it's just not really enough money to make
a difference.
But I appreciate you looking out for getting
every dollar I can in tax deductions, Dave.
Well, we've got a great bonus show for you
today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman
dot com.